la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
j'ai bien noté une observation je vais
lui donner immédiatement la parole et je
donne la parole à Claude Malleret ou
Emmanuel Capu
pour une mise au point au sujet d'un
vote merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais effectivement effectuer une
rectification de vote sur le scrutin
numéro 93 les sénateurs Alain Marc
Franck mais Nonville et Pierre-Jean
vergelin souhaitaient voter pour et le
reste du groupe Les Indépendants
souhaitait s'abstenir
de votre observation ne procès-verbal
est adopté sous les réserves d'usage
cette observation sera donc incluse
elle sera inscrite et publiée au Journal
officiel figurant dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin concerné
l'ordre du jour appelle les explications
de vote et le vote à la tribune du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Rémy frérot pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
S
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues après des
heures de débat y compris sur la
deuxième partie du budget cette année et
qu'ici aucun 49.3 n'aura interrompu la
discussion séance du projet de loi de
finance ne nous aura pas pour autant
rassuré par assuré car les hypothèses
même de ce budget sont irréalistes 1% de
croissance alors que personne n'y croit
pour l'an prochain même pas le président
de la République désormais si j'en crois
ces propos par assuré car l'inflation
risque de se poursuivre au delà de ce
que prévoit le gouvernement et à des
conséquences immédiates sur la vie des
gens et ce sont les meilleurs les plus
précaires qu'il a subissent de plein
fouet par assurer non plus lorsqu'on lit
dans la presse que les discussions entre
le gouvernement et les républicains sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques ne remettraient rien en cause
des dépenses des baisses fiscales
prévues mais exercerait un coup de rabot
supplémentaire sur les public
dès la première année du quinquennat le
gouvernement nous propose donc un
nouveau budget injuste traduisant encore
une fois sa volonté de concentrer les
baisses d'impôts sur les entreprises et
les Français les plus fortunés c'est un
choix que partage la majorité
sénatoriale et que nous ne sommes
malheureusement pas parlés parvenu à
rééquilibrer vous restez dans le même
schéma
réduire les ressources de l'État et
contraindre ses dépenses votre politique
de l'offre est un échec mais vous la
poursuivez coûte que coûte
continuer à dévaloriser les revenus du
travail par rapport aux revenus du
capital c'est cela la réalité de la
politique fiscale qui est menée c'est
cela la vision de la valeur travail par
le gouvernement et nous n'aurons pas été
assez nombreux pour que le Sénat adopte
une véritable taxe sur les super profits
de toutes les grandes entreprises ou
celui-là ou sur la distribution pardon
des super et pourtant la gauche n'aura
pas été seule à défendre un peu plus de
justice et de redistribution je tiens à
le saluer
si le Sénat n'aura pas remis de la
justice dans ce budget notre travaux
n'auront pas été
inutiles néanmoins car nous avons obtenu
des avancées pour les collectivités
territoriales alors que les finances des
collectivités sont mis à mal par
l'inflation et menacée par l'explosion
des coûts de l'énergie nous avons obtenu
que l'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation pour 2023 soit voté par le
Sénat et nous avons voté l'élargissement
du filet de sécurité nous avons
également adopté la baisse du taux de
TVA 5,5 sur les transports publics voilà
une baisse de taux de TVA indispensable
dans la période et nous avons annulé la
suppression de la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée la fameuse CVAE je
rappellerai au gouvernement comme l'a
fait notre président de la commission
des finances Claude Raynal qu'il revient
au Parlement de voter l'impôt
or ni l'Assemblée nationale ni le Sénat
ne se seront prononcés pour la
suppression de la CVAE il faut le noter
enfin malgré leur rejet par l'Assemblée
puis par le Sénat lors de la discussion
du projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques le gouvernement avait
réintroduit dans ce PLF l'encadrement
des dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités par des packs de confiance
qui portent bien mal leur nom et
permettent de sanctionner certaines
collectivités hier soir nous avons à
nouveau supprimer à une majorité
extrêmement large ce mécanisme coercitif
la question est aujourd'hui posée au
gouvernement monsieur le ministre que
restera-t-il de nos votes en faveur des
collectivités dans le budget final avec
ou sans le rouleau compresseur du 49.3
êtes-vous prêt à écouter le Sénat quand
il porte la voie des territoires au-delà
des clivages partisans
car pour le reste
si le volet recettes n'est pas
satisfaisant le volet dépense ne l'est
pas davantage bien sûr des efforts sont
engagés dans le domaine régalien nous
avons su le reconnaître mais aurez-vous
la capacité de les poursuivre dans la
durée et sinon nous sommes très loin du
compte quand on connaît les besoins du
pays en matière sociale sociale dans le
domaine éducatif pour la transition
écologique est-ce que ce budget est un
même de relancer la construction de
logements à l'évidence non est-ce que ce
budget répond aux difficultés immenses
de l'éducation nationale si peu est-ce
que ce budget est à la hauteur de la
crise écologique dont l'été 2022 aura
été l'ultime révélateur non quel que
soit les discours nous en sommes loin
est-ce que le budget permet de faire
face à l'explosion des prix de l'énergie
rien n'est moins sûr comme l'an illustré
nos débats dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi
est-ce que le budget permet de résoudre
les difficultés du ferroviaire et le
risque d'effondrement des transports
publics en Île-de-France non et nos
débats auront montré que le gouvernement
et les amis politiques de Madame
Pécresse se renvoie le la balle sur le
dos des usagers je pourrais poursuivre
sur tant de sujets si j'en avais le
temps mais je ne veux pas
omettre un sujet celui de l'aide
médicale d'État à laquelle s'est attaqué
la majorité sénatoriale il voyant un
outil de lutte contre l'immigration
quand elle ne devrait être considérée
que pour ce qu'elle est un outil de
santé publique indispensable et qui
protège toute notre société
par notre vote nous refuserons donc le
dogme du moins d'impôt qui bénéficie
presque toujours au même c'est-à-dire
les entreprises et les plus riches il
contraint le gouvernement à reporter la
charge sur l'ensemble des Français et à
renoncer à des politiques essentielles
c'est ainsi Monsieur le Ministre que
vous préférez avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage taxer les chômeurs à
défaut des super profits avant d'engager
une réforme des retraites dont le but à
vous et purement comptable c'est ainsi
que nos grands services publics
continuent à se dégrader l'hôpital
l'école les transports publics la
présence de l'État sur les territoires
tous nos débats en témoignent alors
notre vote sera bien sûr négatif
mais avec l'espoir que sur certains
points précis et en particulier pour les
collectivités locales nos travaux nos
débats nos votes étaient utiles c'est
désormais la responsabilité du
gouvernement et de sa majorité relative
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Eric Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste vous
avez la parole
chez le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
je ne doute pas que la citation qui suit
vous fera plaisir
je ferai en sorte qu'à l'avenir il soit
interdit de financer les dépenses de
tous les jours par la dette ces mots les
doigts Monsieur Nicolas Sarkozy dans son
projet présidentiel de 2007
comment ne pas regarder avec ironie ce
budget proposé en déficit à 4,9 %, suite
au vote de la première partie soit près
de 160 milliards d'euros excusés du peu
un besoin d'endettement de 270 milliards
d'euros en 2023 alors du retour du
principe de souveraineté dans le cadre
idéologique de l'exécutif la dépendance
au marché financier demeure plus que
jamais
la révision constitutionnelle a tendue à
sacraliser les lois de programmation des
finances publiques qui sans aller
jusqu'à une règle d'or intangible à
contribuer à réduire le champ
d'expression du Parlement
le droit d'initiative des parlementaires
corseté par les règles de recevabilité
financière ont une nouvelle fois miné
l'examen de ce texte
la responsabilité des parlementaires et
lorsqu'on est examine les dépenses à
chaque moment engagé une
irresponsabilité matérialisée par
l'impossibilité de proposer une dépense
sans piller les crédits d'une autre
politique publique il ne fait décidément
pas être bon pour être progressiste sous
la Cinquième République le calendrier
contraint à déboucher sur des situations
à minima ubuesque si ça n'était si grave
qui ont obligé les parlementaires de
tous les bancs à retirer l'intégralité
de leurs amendements dans le cadre de la
mission agriculture notamment
pressez-vous mes chers collègues le 8ème
49.3 doit d'intervenir au plus vite la
démocratie parlementaire en sorte abîmée
meurtrie du peu des gares qui sont
manifestés à nos débats
le projet de budget sort du Sénat comme
il est arrivé en matière de taxation du
capital le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale se sont rejoints pour
refuser ensemble une nouvelle modalité
d'imposition des multinationales fondées
sur le chiffre d'affaires afin de lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale le
rétablissement d'une véritable exit taxe
pour lutter contre les évadés fiscaux la
taxation des super-profés indispensables
mesure de justice fiscale un
accroissement de la taxe sur les
transactions financières un
accroissement de la taxation des
dividendes versées un accroissement de
la taxation des dividendes reçues il ne
s'agit pas seulement d'un refus d'impôts
supplémentaire il s'agit d'un front
commun d'une union sacrée contre
l'imposition du capital d'un front
commun contre la justice fiscale la plus
élémentaire
la France est une anomalie européenne
dans un contexte d'inflation des prix de
l'énergie des prix de l'alimentation qui
percutent nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes nos entreprises et nos
collectivités pourtant le 28 juillet
2022 quand la présidente de notre groupe
il y a un SSI interroger la première
ministre sur le double langage du
gouvernement en matière de taxation des
super profits à Matignon ont soufflé de
l'air chaud à Bercy en expirait de l'ère
glacial dans un même temps dans le
gouvernement a le secret voici la
conclusion qu'apportait madame borne à
notre collège cite madame la Présidente
nous serons attentifs à ce que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités et nous
serons prêts à agir s'il le faut dans le
cadre du projet de loi finance pour 2023
apparemment il ne l'a pas fallu après
une soixantaine d'heures de débats pour
la première partie du projet de finance
nous avons compris que le gouvernement
refusait d'entrevoir toute taxation
supplémentaire sur le capital
il n'y a pas de versement indu le
dividende
44,3 milliards pour le second ou le seul
second trimestre ce n'est pas un record
il n'y a pas d'inflation différenciée
selon que l'on était ou pas il faut
rehausser toutes les tranches du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu pour le
gouvernement il n'y a pas eu de super
profit du gouvernement allant même
jusqu'à laisser entendre que l'armateur
CMA CGM connaissait une période de
difficulté après des profits records il
n'y a pas de super profit à pas pour
quelques producteurs d'énergie et Total
ne réalise des profits sur son activité
pétrolière que sur ces raffineries il ne
faudrait pas croire comme on l'entend
que les versements de dividende émanent
d'une reprise de l'activité économique
pas du tout il débouche de politique
fiscale accommodante favorable
incitative décidé lors du précédent
quinquennat
à titre d'exemple en 2018 l'année
suivante la mise en place du prélèvement
forfaitaire unique la fameuse flat tax
les dividendes éligibles ont augmenté de
61% à 23,2 milliards d'euros jusqu'en
2020 le niveau était toujours stable
signe que la crise sanitaire n'a pas
enrayé la distribution de dividendes
sans surprise en tout cas pour nous un
petit nombre de ménages les super
dividendes supérieures à un million
d'euros ont eux aussi explosé à 24% des
dividendes versées contre seulement 10%
en 2017 pour rappel un million d'euros
c'est
90334 heures de travail au SMIC horaire
brut
2580 semaines de travail 50 ans de
labeur vous l'aurez compris ce budget
pour 2023 est un budget pour rien si peu
pour nos compatriotes rien pour l'avenir
après ça va refuser les propositions de
recettes il fallait toute l'inventivité
de la majorité sénatoriale et du
gouvernement pour expliquer que nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens allez
voir la facture d'électricité exploser
cette année de 15% après une
augmentation de 4 % l'année précédente
après une envolée de 50% sur les 10
dernières années les Français payaient
avant la guerre en Ukraine les décisions
coupables d'ouverture au marché de
l'énergie et les sous-investissement
chroniques dans l'énergie nucléaire le
bouclier énergie n'y peut rien même à 45
milliards d'euros alors que nous aurions
pu faire mes chers collègues autrement
avec des recettes supplémentaires un mot
enfin sur les collectivités
territoriales dans un contexte où les
élus ne se mettent même plus en colère
ils se sentent condamnés à subir il
bataille dans leur coin de se révolte
pas mais font beaucoup discrètement au
quotidien ils attendaient une rallonge
du petit filet de sécurité pour 2022
indiscutablement imparfait même si le
Sénat l'améliore c'est toujours
insuffisant une seule proposition qui va
et pour répondre à la préoccupation des
élus locaux partout dans tous les
territoires
bon retour au tarif réglementé de
l'électricité et du gaz pour toutes les
collectivités c'est la proposition de
notre groupe qui sera débattue ici même
demain quel sort adviendra de ce texte
qui sort du Sénat le Sénat c'est déjà
lui-même dédiés en faisant voter la
suppression d'amendements adopté
s'appliquant à lui-même une forme de
49-3 interne sans grande illusion nous
le disions en préalable de se débat sur
le budget un huitième 49.3 s'abattra sur
l'Assemblée nationale tout en faignant
le dialogue le gouvernement aura des
coups de France pour retenir les seuls
amendements auxquels et l'accordera ses
préférences nous l'affirmons ici ce
serait un casus belli de revenir sur le
maintien de la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée de l'entreprise sa suppression
la CVAE le gouvernement ça donne à un
jeu de dupe auquel le Sénat a
malheureusement accepté de jouer nous le
regrettons nouveau trop contre ce budget
si mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole de notre colère que
Bernard delcro pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
il y avait la parole
tout au long de l'examen de ce projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 notre groupe a
eu à cœur de suivre une ligne qui nous
semble clair et cohérente guidée par
deux constantes d'une part veiller à
contenir notre déficit et notre
endettement bien sûr en limitant autant
que possible les dépenses de l'État mais
aussi en agissant sur le levier des
recettes parce que nous sommes
convaincus que nous ne réussirons pas à
redresser nos comptes publics sans
accroître nos recettes
deuxième constante l'équité fiscale
sociale et territorial et l'équité ce
n'est pas l'égalité de traitement
c'est au regard de cette ligne que nous
avons défendu la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
super profits et l'argile au-delà du sel
secteur de l'énergie un amendement
soutenu par notre collègue Sylvie
vermeiller cette mesure aurait
pré-permie en premier lieu de compenser
pour partie les dépenses exceptionnelles
que portent ce budget et que nous
soutenons par ailleurs pour protéger les
Français les entreprises les
collectivités face à la hausse des prix
notamment ceux de l'énergie en second
lieu un moment où on demande beaucoup
aux Français comment expliquer que les
très très grandes entreprises les plus
grandes entreprises qui accumulent des
profits records parfois en raison de la
crise actuelle ne contribue pas
davantage à la solidarité nationale à
dépenses exceptionnelle mesure
exceptionnelle
c'est aussi
pour ne pas priver l'état de 4 milliards
d'euros de recettes cette année et 8
milliards l'année prochaine que nous
avons défendu le report de la
suppression de la CVAE cette suppression
ne nous paraît pas opportunes au moment
où tant de dépenses sont nécessaires
pour faire face à la crise et que deux
surcroît les données macroéconomiques
sur lesquelles est fondée ce budget sont
fragiles au regard des incertitudes qui
pèsent sur le contexte européen et
mondial
par ailleurs nous nous réjouissons que
le Sénat nous est suivi sur la
suppression de plusieurs niches fiscales
un sujet cher à notre collègue Michel
canvett dans un double objectif
d'efficacité budgétaire et de justice
fiscale parmi elles la suppression d'une
niche implicite sur la transmission du
patrimoine des plus fortunés qui
contourne l'impôt sur le revenu en
exploitant une faille du dispositif
nouveau des PER une anomalie qui
coûterait plusieurs milliards d'euros à
l'État selon certaines estimations
ainsi plusieurs mesures souvent de
justice fiscale adoptés par le Sénat en
première partie ont permis de réduire
notre déficit de 6,9 milliards et sans
doute davantage parce qu'un certain
nombre de mesures n'ont plus être
chiffrées par vos services sur le volet
budgétaire le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 poursuit sa stratégie de
hausse des budgets de plusieurs
ministères régaliens la justice la santé
l'enseignement la sécurité la défense
nous considérons que ces hausses sont
nécessaires pour permettre à ces
ministères de mener à bien leur mission
qui sont essentielles pour le pays
concernant les collectivités locales sur
la DGF notre groupe n'était pas
favorable à une réponse uniforme pour
toutes les collectivités parce que nous
savons bien que derrière les moyennes
parfois flatteuses se cachent de fortes
disparité aussi pour tenir compte de
cette réalité et par ces mesures
d'équité nous soutenions le choix
d'augmenter la DGF en ciblant les
collectivités les plus fragiles nous
avons eu un long débat monsieur le
ministre sur la réforme des critères de
répartition de la DSR et des voix se
sont élevées sur tous les bandes pour
que les critères de la longueur de
voirie communale soit maintenue sa
suppression pénaliserait les plus
petites communes nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour entendre cette
voix une année du Sénat
concernant la dotation aux communes pour
la protection de la biodiversité et la
valorisation des aminés rurales le Sénat
a renforcé les moyens qui lui sont
consacrés pour une meilleure
reconnaissance de l'apport de la
ruralité à la préservation de notre
environnement
c'est un message positif adressé aux
maires des campagnes de France et nous
souhaitons vivement que dans le texte
final le gouvernement conserve cette
belle avancée en matière
d'investissement le nouveau fond vert
votez doté de 2 milliards d'euros dont
la gestion sera confiée au préfet de
département et nous soutenons cette idée
viendra compléter
utilement la DETR et la décile pour
soutenir les investissements des
collectivités locales enfin le Sénat a
adopté la réintégration des dépenses
d'aménagement de terrain dans
l'éligibilité au FCTVA une mesure vous
le savez très attendue des cellules
locaux
je veux pour terminer évoquer les
mesures visant à protéger les
collectivités les ménages et les
entreprises face à l'explosion du coup
de l'énergie
nous soutenons le plafonnement de la
hausse des tarifs réglementés en faveur
des ménages et des petites collectivités
ainsi que l'amortisseur électricité en
faveur des collectivités et des
entreprises qui nous semblent bien
ciblées et mieux calibrer à 180 euros le
mégawattheure plutôt qu'à 325 comme
prévu initialement nous voulons saluer
cette avancée nous avons aussi soutenu
l'amendement du Gouvernement voté par le
Sénat vendredi pour élargir les
ligibilité au bouclier tarifaires gaz
électricité notamment en faveur des
EHPAD et des résidences autonomiques en
revanche le Sénat a revu les critères
d'éligibilité aux filets de sécurité
énergie en faveur des collectivités pour
le rendre plus simple plus claire plus
efficace et nous semble important que
vous conserviez au final un dispositif
simplifié et suffisamment ouvert
monsieur le ministre au terme de ces
semaines de débat notre groupe tient
d'abord à vous remercier pour votre
présence continue votre écoute et la
facilité de nos échanges même si nous
aurions souhaité parfois davantage
d'ouverture vers les propositions du
Sénat notre groupe de l'Union centriste
à la caséineanimité votre rat le projet
de budget
issu des débats du Sénat
merci mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
donné la parole
notre collègue Jean-Louis Masson pour la
Réunion administrative des sénateurs qui
ne figurent sur la liste d'aucun groupe
et Monsieur Masson à 3 minutes pour
donner l'explication de son vote
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
chers collègues
ce projet de loi de finances est très
inquiétant pour l'avenir car la
politique suivie actuellement est une
fuite en avant en matière budgétaire
elle nous conduit dans le mur et nous
risquons de nous retrouver dans la
situation de la Grèce
une réflexion d'ensemble est en
particulier nécessaire sur les
conséquences de la politique du quoi
qu'il en coûte et sur les séquelles pour
la France du blocus économique imposé
contre la Russie
tout d'abord la politique du quoi qu'il
en coûte et bien cette politique conduit
à un endettement massif en faisant
croire qu'on peut toujours continuer à
dépenser sans se soucier des
conséquences pour l'avenir cependant il
n'y a pas d'argent magique or depuis le
président Sarkozy inclus tous nos
dirigeants se comportent comme la cigale
de la femme et il ne faut pas s'étonner
si notre situation France financière et
beaucoup plus dégradé que celle de
l'Allemagne il est vraiment temps de
dire à nos concitoyens la vérité à ce
sujet
par ailleurs
la guerre en Ukraine ou plutôt la
décision cautionnée par la France
d'organiser un blocus économique contre
la Russie est une autre source de
difficultés ce blocus économique a en
effet des conséquences très graves pour
notre économie
probablement plus grave pour nous que
pour la Russie ce qui est vraiment un
comble
ce matin une grande radio nationale sur
une sur une grande radio nationale deux
économistes ont ainsi confirmé que le
seul boycott du gaz et du pétrole russe
sans compter le reste est à l'origine de
plus de 50% de l'inflation là aussi nos
concitoyens qui sont victimes d'une
hausse galopante des prix doivent être
informés et conscients de cette réalité
voilà Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues voilà les raisons pour
lesquelles je voterai contre le projet
de budget pour 2023
la parole est maintenant président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
après une première partie du budget
sensiblement augmenter avec la réforme
de la loi organique relativement loi de
finance et de la croissance continue
d'année Lyon mon amendement nous avons
achevé hier soir plutôt ce matin à 1h30
donc l'examen de la seconde partie de ce
tlfl comme je l'avais dit lors de la
discussion générale le 17 novembre le
Sénat a délibéré une délégation parfois
contrainte par une nouvelle règle
d'examen des missions en temps programmé
des rails qui ont été dans l'ensemble
allez citation du président de la
commission des finances respectées par
notre assemblée que va-t-il subiter des
nombreuses modifications adoptées après
cette première lecture alors que la
réunion de la commission mixte paritaire
a été avancée à ce soir et que selon
toute probabilité on se dirige de
nouveau vers un nouveau 49.3 à
l'Assemblée
c'est ce que nous regarderons avec
intérêt à la situation actuelle est
inédite par les deux par les pour les
deux lois de finance rectificatives
c'est amené l'Assemblée et le Sénat ont
su trouver des terrains d'antanques
évitant ainsi de repartir pour de
nouvelles lectures
ne pourrait-on pas en être ainsi pour le
PS j'appelle la modération des uns et
des autres afin de préserver la
crédibilité à terme de nos institutions
les amendements proposés par le
gouvernement et adopté par le Sénat ont
de fortes chances de perdurer
suppression de la condition d'âge de
décès d'un époux à 5 combattants pour la
demi-part de sa veuve modalités
d'indexation de la déduction pour
épargne précaution ajustement de la
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
bénéfices des énergéticiens ainsi qu'à
ses annonce d'ouverture de crédit dans
le domaine de la sécurité civile lutte
contre l'incendie la justice judiciaire
l'alimentation des étudiants
l'enseignant agricole la revarisation
des salaires de la science a été
asociale surtout au moment à 6 milliards
d'euros au crédit de la mission écologie
et quand dans le Bouclier tarifaire à
l'habitat collectif et réévaluant des
charges du service public de l'énergie
le rejet par la majorité c'est la loyale
de 4 missions en particulier la cohésion
des territoires et l'agriculture n'est
pas très surprenant il y en a tous les
ans et il nous amène à voter sur un
budget amputé de nombreux crédits même
si la question des missions de l'État
dans certains domaines peut légitimement
légitimement se poser surtout avec le
déficit encore massif que nous apprêtons
à souscrire en 2023 ce déficit pourrait
être aggravé par les imprévus de la
situation internationale des prévisions
de croissance du gouvernement restent
crédible bien que la prévision dans ce
domaine s'apparente souvent à de la
météorologie la réforme phare de la
première partie était assez pression sur
deux ans de la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée la fameuse CVE la
majorité c'est la toriale a tenté une
solution immédiate après avoir à la voix
à la préservatoire à la fois la
compétitivité des entreprises et les
finances des collectivités avec un coût
critères non négligeable pour l'État
mais la CVAE a survécu du moins océan
ces dernières années la réforme de la
fiscalité des radium les réformes la
fiscalité ont été marqués par un recours
depuis dans le but fréquents et
diversifié aux recettes de la TVA
d'abord pour le financement des régions
bientôt poursuivi les départements et de
façon massive pour celui de la sécurité
sociale en période d'inflation des prix
à la consommation cette évolution n'est
pas défavorable au finances publiques
même si le consommateur en paix
concrètement la facture le rapport de la
Cour des comptes cette tonne sur la
situation des finances locales était
éclairant au regard des comparaison
international les finales des
collectivités locales ne représentant
froid que 20% environ de la déphases
publiques derrière les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale et celle de l'État
c'est bien nettoyer européenne où les
dépenses des collectivités locales
représentent la moyenne 40% de la
dépense publique
[Musique]
pas été rencontré le même succès en
particulier dans le développement local
et durable le secteur médico-social et
le secteur patrimonial et culturel sur
la taxe d'aménagement la suppression de
la réforme de la répartition au sein du
bloc communal voter l'an dernier nous
paraît préférable dans la mesure où la
répartition des charges d'aménagement
varie beaucoup en fonction de sa
territoire la répartition du produit de
l'imposition forfaitaire sur les
entreprises de réseau l'hifair reste
assuré complexe qui mériterait davantage
de débats elle doit en tout cas veuillez
à rester incitative pour les acteurs
locaux pour l'acceptation de
l'implantation des parcs éoliens ou
solaires une nouveauté du PLF en 2023 et
la possibilité
d'amander sur les indicateurs du
performance et plus largement sur les
plafonds d'emploi de l'État et de ses
opérateurs nous verrons là s'il s'agit
bien d'un levier d'amélioration de
l'action publique ou d'un gadget de plus
en conclusion
après ces différentes remarques et au vu
des nombreux points évoqués les membres
du groupe RDSE voteront majoritairement
pour l'adoption de CPF 2023 avec
néanmoins diversité et liberté de votre
oblige quelques abstentions
monsieur le Président la parole est à
notre collègue Jérôme Bacher pour le
groupe les républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
tout d'abord c'est le premier projet de
loi de finance que nous examinons avec
la nouvelle loi organique sur les lois
de finances que le président rénal c'est
athlé a bien faire respecter et rien que
pour cela pour avoir tenu les aussi les
délais dans ce nouveau temps contraint
il faut le remercier mais je remercierai
d'abord le rapporteur général qui nous
aura permis avec vous monsieur le
ministre d'avoir un dialogue une
contribution une présence
vous aurez compris en creux de qui nous
notons l'absence ce budget c'est le
budget de la volatilité de la
variabilité de l'instabilité et de
l'inflation
tout d'abord
la variabilité y compris y compris y
compris de la vie du gouvernement
prenons l'article 40 quater hier encore
monsieur le ministre vous avez maintenu
cette ce point sur les nouveaux ou les
anciens contrats de Cahors de Lourdes on
a eu tous les termes qui sont apparus
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la
première ministre nous avait dit le
contraire à l'Association des maires de
France et nous étions nombreux aux côtés
de nos élus locaux et bien ses avis un
peu
fluctuants ne facilite pas le débat à un
moment où on aurait besoin d'un CAP d'un
CAP politique la cape de politique
économique d'un CAP politique tout court
alors monsieur le ministre vous avez eu
aussi de l'inflation l'inflation dans
les amendements mes chers collègues nous
sommes passés en disant de 500 à 3000
amendements sur cette loi de finances
pourquoi pas c'est le droit du Parlement
et nous l'avons utilisé à plein après
que l'Assemblée nationale en a eu été
largement privé
c'est aussi l'inflation dans la hauteur
et les milliards des amendements un
amendement du Gouvernement fait plus de
25 milliards et donc un sous amendement
a fait près de 6 milliards nous n'avons
jamais vu de tels mouvements sur des
amendements donc il faut peut-être
retrouver par du calme là-dessus pour
bien légiférer trop d'instabilité
enfin on a eu aussi de l'instabilité sur
l'article d'équilibre étant donné ce qui
s'est passé on s'est trompé de quel d'un
chiffre moins d'un chiffre plus c'est
sûr ce ne sont que des milliards d'euros
alors à la fin sur l'article d'équilibre
nous obtenons effectivement à
déséquilibre et le budget que nous
allons voter très largement dans le
groupe les républicains n'est pas un
budget complet nous en avons bien
conscience monsieur le ministre c'est
aussi la limite de l'article 40 qui ne
nous permet pas de reconstruire
totalement un budget mes chers collègues
nous le savons
mais nous faisons des propositions nous
vous faisons des propositions car on ne
peut pas continuer d'avoir un budget en
déséquilibre 500 milliards de budgets
156 milliards de déficits
270 milliards d'empreintes longères à
faire 270 milliards pour 500 milliards
de budget l'année dernière je vous
disais qu'on était à la moitié du budget
financé par la dette nous sommes
dorénavant au-delà de la moitié alors
évidemment ça ne peut pas continuer
comme cela par car d'un côté vous nous
proposez la baisse des impôts et nous
pouvons y souscrire sur la tvae nous
dans le groupe les républicains nous
sommes pour la suppression de la CVAE
mais pas comme cela ce n'est ni à faire
c'est de l'improvisation comme vous avez
improvisé sur la redevance et vous nous
avez toujours pas proposé de régime pour
remplacer en 2024 ce qui doit être sur
la CVAE c'est la même chose votre
mécanisme de compensation aux
collectivités locales ne convient pas de
convient pas
alors c'est au travail que nous vous
appelons et un travail de concertation
avant de prendre des mesures comme ça à
l'emporte-pièce sur des milliards qui
concernent les collectivités et la
compétitivité de la France
nous vous avons fait des propositions
pour reprendre l'invitation du FMI mais
aussi ce que le Sénat a voté lors de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques nous vous devons réorienter
nous avons diminué les dépenses nous
étions engagés dans la loi de
programmation en cohérence nous avons
diminué les dépenses et à la fin nous
réduisons aussi le déficit public hormis
l'émission que nous avons refusé et
pourquoi avons-nous refuser certaines
missions mes chers collègues ce n'est
pas comme ça des tocades que nous
aurions c'est que ce sont des secteurs
pour lesquels ce ne sont pas les crédits
qui manquent c'est la réforme c'est le
courage
absence de réforme sur l'immigration et
c'est pour cela que nous avons rejeté
les crédits notre agriculture est dans
une très mauvaise passe et ici les
rapports sont nombreux pour le souligner
nos alertes sont récurrentes et là
encore nous avons refusé les crédits ce
n'est pas que nous n'avons pas besoin
d'argent pour notre agriculture pour la
moderniser pour la rendre plus bio plus
écologique ce n'est pas ça le sujet
c'est que vous ne travaillez pas à la
réforme et lorsque vous faisons par
exemple des propositions très bienvenues
comme celle de Christine Ava pour éviter
500 millions d'euros de dépenses pour
acheter des voitures chinoises on
améliore à la fois le déficit public et
à la fois le déficit commercial voilà le
double bénéfice que nous vous proposons
alors monsieur le ministre avant de
terminer je voudrais quand même car il y
aura un 49-3 nul ici l'ignore nous ne
sommes pas des garennes de 6 semaines
il faut retenir quelques points
d'attention et c'est là dessus que je
voudrais terminer évidemment il y a la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
évidemment il y a le filet de sécurité
tel que proposé par le Sénat qui a reçu
Laval de l'AMF de la DF et de l'ARS les
territoires réunis ils ont donné la
ravale il y a aussi et nous avons la RT
très fort et les entreprises continuent
de travailler avec vous je le sais je
vous sais attentif monsieur le ministre
là-dessus au mécanisme de contribution
de la rente infrar marginale des
installations électriques notamment avec
des tarifs revalorisés chez nous 145
euros du mégawattheure pour le biogaz
ça doit être cela oui
je veux pas me tromper sur les chiffres
et puis également nous avons alerté sur
la TGAP si nous avons gelé la TGAP c'est
qu'en période d'inflation augmentée
aussi la TGAP le risque c'est l'effet
gilets jaunes taxe carbone + prix de de
de des carburants c'est la même chose
pour l'électricité enfin il y a le FCTVA
sur lequel nous y sommes très attachés
et dans la dernière ligne droite qui me
reste pensez à la TVA pour les chevaux
merci beaucoup
les paroles
est à notre collègue Emmanuel Capu pour
le groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
après trois semaines de débat de jour
comme de nuit 26 débats sur l'émission
et les comptes spéciaux et plus de 2500
amendements examinés nous achevons
l'examen du premier budget de ce nouveau
quinquennat aujourd'hui
et puisque c'est le moment sont partagés
je tiens tout d'abord à remercier au nom
de mon groupe Les Indépendants la
commission des finances et le
gouvernement pour l'engagement pour leur
engagement cet engagement qui a permis
la bonne tenue des débats et la qualité
de notre travail ça vaut
particulièrement pour vous monsieur le
ministre des comptes publics et pour
vous monsieur le rapporteur général
vous avez passé ici de longues heures et
vous allez toujours pris le plus grand
soin pour répondre à nos questions et à
nos interpellations cela améliore
grandement la qualité de nos débats
je tiens également remercier le
président de la commission des finances
qui n'a pas ménagé son temps mais qui a
su ménager le nôtre
en invitant régulièrement nos collègues
les plus prolixes à davantage de
concision
nos débats ont été riches lors de la
deuxième partie comme il l'avait été
lors de la première nous avons pu
débattre de sujets importants pour les
collectivités locales et pour les élus
je pense notamment à la mise en place du
fond vert cet outil sera à la
disposition des acteurs de terrain ils
permettra de faire avancer la transition
écologique par des actes plutôt que par
des polémiques c'est ça l'écologie du
réel c'est ça l'écologie de l'action
nous avons également renforcé les
dispositifs pour aider les collectivités
à faire face à l'inflation
aujourd'hui le coût de l'énergie c'est
l'angoisse majeur des élus locaux ils
savent pouvoir compter sur l'état mais
ils attendent maintenant les actes
je ne reviens pas sur les dispositifs
votés en première partie notamment le
filet de sécurité dont les conditions
d'éligibilité ont été supprimées et
l'indexation de la DGF sur l'inflation
ces mesures répondaient aux inquiétudes
des collectivités mais comme je l'ai
déjà dit à la fin de la première partie
ces mesures ne sont pas ciblées sur les
collectivités qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est pourquoi notre groupe a déposé
plusieurs amendements visant un encadrer
ces dispositifs non pas pour pénaliser
certaines collectivités mais bien pour
soulager les finances publiques dans
leur ensemble
c'est dans cet état d'esprit dans ce
même état d'esprit que nous avons abordé
l'article 40 quaters il réintroduisait
dans le PLF l'article 23 de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
y instaurant des contrats de confiance
nouvelle version adoucie des contrats de
Cahors ces accords vise à maîtriser
l'évolution des dépenses locales et à
renforcer le crédit de la France ce
n'est pas rien
notre groupe avait toutefois exprimé
clairement au moment du projet de loi de
programmation ces réserves vis-à-vis de
mécanismes contraignants ces réserves
persistent notamment à cause des
sanctions qui sont trop sévères pour les
collectivités
mais nous pensons plus opportun
d'améliorer les solutions proposées par
le gouvernement plutôt que de les
rejeter en bloc nous avons proposé de
conserver le mécanisme de suivi des
dépenses tout en supprimant les
pénalités associées nous aurions ainsi
préféré que le Sénat puisse aboutir à un
mécanisme de contrôle des finances
locales sans mesure coercitives car
c'est là que le blés
c'est ce que nous souhaitions
j'espère que dans le cadre de la navette
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
cette accord aboutira sur ce sujet qui
concerne à la fois les collectivités et
nos finances publiques
à ce propos je me réjouis que notre
assemblée est plus réduire le déficit
public de 0,2 points de PIB faire c'est
moins que l'objectif que le Sénat
s'était fixé en loi de programmation
mais c'est une avancée prudente que
notre groupe s'allume d'ailleurs la
réduction d'édifices est formellement
bien supérieure à 0 de pointe mais cette
hausse est en play
car le budget sur lequel nous devons
nous prencer est amputé de certaines
missions
et non des moindres or cette carence
brouille le message politique que nous
envoyons
quel est le message envoyé à nos
agriculteurs qui compte sur notre
soutien lorsque le Sénat ne vote pas les
crédits de la mission agriculture
alimentation forêt à faire rurales
quel est le message envoyé à nos élus
locaux qui comptent aussi sur notre
soutien lorsque le Sénat ne vote pas les
crédits de la mission cohésion des
territoires
quel est enfin quel est le message
envoyé à tous nos compatriotes qui
souhaitent que notre politique
migratoire soit à la fois plus juste et
plus ferme lorsque le Sénat ne vote pas
les crédits de la mission immigration
asile et intégration
rejetez ces missions c'est convenir
qu'il y a un problème
certes je l'entends bien mais cela ne
dit rien de la solution souhaitée
ça ne dit pas ce que nous voulons mais
juste ce que nous ne voulons pas
en conséquence le texte ne nous paraît
pas parfaitement équilibré à ce stade
c'est pourquoi
notre groupe s'absiendra majoritairement
et que certains le font pour
conclure mes chers collègues messieurs
les ministres enfin pardon monsieur le
ministre
je voudrais dire un mot des communes
nouvelles
à l'initiative de notre collègue que
j'entends Françoise Gatel le Sénat a
envoyé un message clair
il faut de toute urgence pallier la
baisse de dotation qui menace certaines
communes nouvelles le dispositif retenu
par le Sénat est peut-être à améliorer
techniquement
mais j'espère que nous parviendrons à
une solution de compromis qui répondra
aux attentes des élus locaux je pense
notamment mes chers collègues si vous me
permettez aux communes de Douai en Anjou
et de Segré en Anjou pour elle il y a
une urgence absolue la situation n'est
absolument pas tenable mais je pensais
évidemment
aux quelques autres communes qui sont
concernées je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
Breuillet pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
la parole
le ciel président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
sur le rapporteur général chers
collègues d'abord après 2600 amendements
des dizaines d'heures de débats je
voudrais vous dire Monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général merci pour ce moment
ce projet de loi de finances procède de
choix qui nous conviennent pas
d'inspiration libérale baissant l'impôt
des entreprises refusant toute nouvelle
contribution de ceux qui accumulent
richesse et dividendes et donnant moins
à ceux qui ont peu il accentuera un peu
plus les inégalités et les écarts sans
cesse plus grands des revenus de notre
pays
selon l'Insee les mesures sociales et
fiscales intervenues en 2020 et 2021
profite surtout à la moitié la plus
aisée de la population elles induisent
une augmentation du niveau de vie allant
jusqu'à 470 euros annuels en moyenne
pour les personnes entre les 7e et 8e
des cils contre 90 euros pour les 50%
les plus modestes
l'inflation actuelle accentuera encore
cette réalité brutale car elle pénalise
bien plus les catégories modestes et
moyennes
la suppression de la CVAE privant l'état
de 8 milliards de recettes en pleine
période de crise serait un manquablement
répercuté sur les ménages via la TVA ou
via l'endettement et contribuerait ainsi
à l'affaiblissement du service public le
bien commun de ceux qui n'ont pas de
patrimoine c'est pourquoi nous nous y
sommes opposés notre philosophie notre
projet politique celui de la sobriété et
structuré sur une qualité de vie
garantie pour tous et par le fait de
demander plus d'efforts à ceux qui
accumulent toujours plus plus de
richesses plus de bien plus de
dividendes et bien sûr qui polluent
également plus
si l'immense majorité de nos amendements
a été rejetés par la majorité
sénatoriale notre groupe a tout de même
tenté d'exposer les termes possibles
d'un avenir socialement plus juste
désirable et durable sur la mission
enseignement scolaire qui concerne 12
millions d'élèves nous avons voté la
hausse indispensable de 3,7 milliards de
crédit mais la crise est d'une
profondeur bien au-delà du simple sujet
budgétaire le budget de la mission
économie traduit une politique très
généreuse d'aide non conditionnée trop
fortement voire essentiellement destinée
aux grands groupes et sans en faire un
outil efficace de la bifurcation
écologique comme si essaye les USA la
hausse des crédits de la justice que
nous avons approuvée pour indispensable
auquel ne suffira pas à remettre à flot
un système à bout de souffle sur le
volet sécurité civile notre déception
est grande les moyens ne sont pas à la
hauteur car les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique sont et seront
chaque année plus graves
les crédits de la mission santé ne
suffiront pas l'hôpital public
s'effondre et déserts médicaux
s'étendent nombre de Français renoncent
au soin la santé mentale est au projet
de loi de finances ce que la psychiatrie
est à la médecine un parent pauvre et
délaissé il faudrait pourtant aider les
adolescents nombreux en souffrance
psychique leur souffrance et celle de
leur famille sont si grandes ce projet
de loi de finance n'a pas non plus assez
pris la mesure de la détresse de
nombreuses étudiants nous avons proposé
plus de justice sociale pour les bourses
insuffisantes rejetées rejeter aussi
toutes les mesures pour le logement pour
permettre aux jeunes de se loger et de
vivre au pays malgré la multiplication
des Airbnb des résidences secondaires et
l'envoler de la spéculation immobilière
rejetez aussi les aides aux autorités
organisatrices de mobilité partout en
France alors que d'autres pays européens
si engouffrer réellement
comment peut-on consacrer des milliards
au déplacements automobile et
simultanément refusé d'aider les
transports en commun la TVA à 5-5
monsieur le ministre sera-t-elle
maintenu nous avons défendu
l'augmentation du versement mobilité
augmentation qui avait été demandé par
Valérie Pécresse pour l'Île-de-France
mais refusé par la majorité sénatoriale
la désorganisation des transports va
coûter cher à la planète en pollution
chers aux usagers d'abord mes chers
aussi aux entreprises car les salariés
ne pourront assumer leurs horaires de
travail avec un système totalement
désorganisé le gouvernement a fait la
sourde oreille durant tous nos débats
faire payer 90 euros aux usagers
d'Île-de-France alors que les conditions
de transport sont épouvantables et se
dégradent encore c'est inacceptable dans
le champ culturel l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public reste incertain et
les menaces qu'au nom de la sécurité des
Jeux Olympiques vous faites peser sur la
saison 2024
un secteur culturel déjà fortement
fragilisé malgré un effort budgétaire
réel nous craignons des baisses des
budgets locaux pour la culture qui
réalise 9,8 milliards d'euros
d'investissement les trois quarts de
l'investissement public si les
collectivités se trouvent face à ces
choix ce n'est pas de gaieté de coeur
cette loi de finances pourrait grâce aux
amendements sénatoriaux préserver un peu
leur capacité à agir avec l'indexation
de la DGF et un bouclier énergie
simplifié étendu mais respecterez vous
ces choix avec l'article 44 TER vous
avez choisi de passer au dessus de tous
les votes de l'assemblée nationale et du
Sénat cela témoigne d'une défiance à
l'encontre des collectivités et du
Parlement les collectivités ont besoin
de confiance pas de contrat enfin d'un
point de vue environnemental nous sommes
loin très loin du compte il aurait été
possible de faire au fond le même effort
que vous faites pour le bouclier
carburant ou mieux encore celui fait
face au covid car la crise et d'une
ampleur similaire au lendemain de la COP
27 à la veille de la COP biodiversité la
continuité budgétaire à peine améliorée
est un contresens historique le report à
plus tard d'une véritable rénovation
thermique pénalisera de nombreux foyers
nos émissions de CO2 et notre balance
commerciale par la dépendance aux
fossiles la défense des écosystèmes la
biodiversité la forêt la préservation de
la ressource en eau l'adaptation de
notre agriculture vers l'agroécologie
doivent être érigés en grande cause
nationale c'est une nécessité pour nous
pour nos enfants et pour nos
petits-enfants enfin ce budget est rendu
un sincère par le choix de la majorité
sénatoriale de supprimer des missions
entières plus d'APL plus de passeport de
carte d'identité plus d'aide aux
agriculteurs plus d'hébergement
d'urgence plus de politique migratoire
pour afficher une baisse de la dépense
publique vous laisserez donc le
gouvernement des si des sols pour notre
part nous ne voterons pas budget qui
privilégie les baisses d'impôts aux
urgences sociales et écologiques et dont
par ailleurs toute votre communication
monsieur le ministre nous annonce votre
choix de le 49-3izet dès la semaine
prochaine
merci
[Applaudissements]
de donner la parole à notre collègue
Didier Rambaud pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
[Applaudissements]
la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues il y a un an
une motion tendance à opposer la
question préalable avait été adoptée
excluant ainsi tout débat sur les
différentes missions budgétaires du PLF
pour 2022 notre assemblée était alors
privé des nocturnes budgétaires hivernal
certains en sont peut-être nostalgiques
vu le dépassement des records
d'amendement discutés cette année que ce
soit en première partie avec 1741
amendements discuté ou en seconde partie
mes chers collègues ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 a été l'occasion
d'adopter des mesures positives pour
notre pays pour les ménages les services
publics et les collectivités à commencer
par le pouvoir d'achat des ménages avec
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui représente 6,2 milliards
d'euros
un budget au service de nos missions
régaliennes également avec des efforts
considérables pour le ministère de la
Justice un budget en augmentation de 8%
pour la troisième année consécutive pour
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
aussi avec la revalorisation des
salaires des enseignants l'objectif
étant le salaire minimum de 2000 euros
de net par mois en début de carrière un
budget à l'écoute des collectivités
enfin avec l'augmentation en 2023 de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement de
320 millions d'euros après des années de
baisse le maire que j'ai été entre 2001
et 2017 s'en souvient douloureusement
-14 milliards d'euros puis de
stabilisation entre 2017 et 2022 la DGF
augmente pour la première fois depuis 13
ans et je veux encore une fois encore la
rappeler en cette période si délicate
pour les collectivités locales
cependant force est de constater qu'à
l'issue de son examen au Sénat le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 est dénaturé
raison pour laquelle le groupe RDPI
s'abstindra sur l'ensemble du texte en
cohérence avec notre position
d'abstention sous la première partie du
texte en réalité dès l'examen de cette
première partie les fondations de ce
budget pour 2023 était défiguré les
amendements adoptés sur l'indexation de
la DGF et sur le filet de sécurité ils
sont pour quelque chose mais la
suppression
ubuesque de la réforme de la cotisation
sur la valeur ajoutée des entreprises
enfoncent définitivement le clou idée de
dégrèvement improvisé pour justifier
votre report après les sénatoriales
entre les réunions de commission et
l'examen du texte en séance oui ubuesque
Roger des amendements de suppression de
la réforme de la CVAE puis dégrèvement
improvisé pour ensuite rejeter l'article
que que vous aviez pourtant modifié le
gouvernement vous proposer de supprimer
la CVAE mesure qui bénéficierait à 530
000 entreprises dont 25% des gains se
réfléchit vers l'industrie chers
collègues je m'interrogeais déjà sur la
cohérence de la majorité c'est notoriale
en cette fin de période automnale tout
en saluant la courtoisie et l'écoute de
notre rapporteur général je constate que
mes demandes sont visiblement restés
lettres mortes bien naturel sur le fond
en première partie le projet de loi de
finances les tout autant d'un point de
vue budgétaire en deuxième partie
arrêtons-nous un instant sur le bilan de
l'examen d'émissions agriculture
cohésion des territoires immigration
immigration asile et intégration
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État et on l'a vu hier soir aussi
lors de l'examen de la mission aide
publique au développement avec un
amendement de suppression de 200
millions d'euros les crédits de ces
missions pourtant primordiales dans
l'ossature budgétaire ont été rejetés
résultat 33 milliards d'économies en
trompe l'oeil si TLF était issu du Sénat
il y aurait par exemple plus de
financement des aPL
ni de financement pour les maisons
services plus de financement pour le
logement des personnes en difficulté
nous sommes tous ici d'accord pour
maîtriser la dépense publique mais mon
groupe ne partage absolument pas les
cibles choisies pour les réaliser en
votant des économies non structurantes
le déficit s'établirait à 3,7% du PIB
mais ce chiffre est factice il reflète
tout simplement la suppression sèche de
politique publique qui sont pourtant
essentielles cela étant je tiens quand
même à saluer un certain nombre
d'amendements adoptés
issus de notre groupe qui s'avère
positif pour les territoires ultramarins
à Wallis-et-Futuna qui disposera de 450
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour le
remplacement des 8 générateurs
d'hémodialyse à Mayotte avec la
prolongation de la majoration à des
seuils de revenus fiscaux une référence
en dessous desquels les contribuables
modestes ou âgés peuvent bénéficier des
allègements de taxes foncières
en Guadeloupe avec une augmentation du
tarif d'imposition forfaitaire sur les
entreprises de réseau appliquées au
central géothermique électrogène
essentiels par exemple pour la commune
de Bouillante sans oublier des mesures
plus générales comme la prolongation de
plusieurs dispositifs de défiscalisation
jusqu'à 2029 pour les collectivités
d'outre-mer l'augmentation de 4 millions
d'euros pour les crédits dédiés à la
lutte contre l'habitat insalubre ou
encore le relèvement de la franchise de
taxation à l'octroi de mer et à la TVA
pour les biens qui font l'objet de
petits envois non commerciaux de 205 à
400 euros de nouveau ou une mesure de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat des ménages
compte tenu de l'adoption de ces
amendements qui justifieront le vote
positif de mes collègues ultramarins
vous comprendrez néanmoins qu'une
majorité de notre groupe RDPI
s'abstiendra sur ce vote sur le vote de
ce projet de loi de finance pour 2023
merci merci mes chers collègues
le Sénat va maintenant procéder au vote
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 je rappelle que le
scrutin public est de droit
et conformément à l'article 60 bis de
notre règlement
scrutin public aura lieu à la tribune
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
placerons à bulletin bleu dans l'urne
placé à cet effet ce qui souhaite
voter contre
placerons un bulletin rouge
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
placerons un bulletin blanc
vos bulletins de vote personnelle sont
vous le savez à votre disposition dans
une enveloppe placée dans le tiroir du
pupitre si vous êtes titulaire d'une
délégation de vote vous y trouverez
également une enveloppe qui contient les
bulletins de vote de votre délégué
je vais demander à
deux collègues secrétaires du Sénat de
m'aider à superviser les opérations de
vol en l'occurrence Madame Françoise
Ferrat et Monsieur Joël Gueriot
ça va
voici le moment de plus grande
incertitude de la journée
je vais tirer au sort la lettre par
laquelle commencera l'appel nominale
la lettre H
[Applaudissements]
après
après ce moment d'émotion pour ceux dont
le nom commencer par un jeu
nous allons procéder à l'appel
j'appelle madame Henri B
monsieur Hassani
madame avait
monsieur est
Monsieur Hervé
madame Herzog
monsieur Houpert
monsieur Hugonnet
monsieur Husson
lettre I
c'est bon
madame Humbert
lettre J
madame Jacquemet
madame Jacques
Monsieur Jacques
monsieur Janssen
madame jasmin
monsieur Joly
monsieur jaumier
madame Joseph
madame Gisèle Jourda
madame Muriel jourdat
lettre K
monsieur caner
monsieur carucci
monsieur Kern
monsieur Kerrouche
monsieur coulismo et côté
lettre L
madame de La Gontrie
madame de La provoté
monsieur l'abbé
monsieur Lafont
monsieur Lagourgue
monsieur Laugier
Monsieur Daniel Laurent
Monsieur Pierre Laurent
Madame Christine Lavarde
monsieur le gueux
Monsieur Madame Louis roux
monsieur Lefebvre
monsieur deleige
monsieur Lemoine
monsieur Leroy
madame Letard
Monsieur Lévy
monsieur lévrier
madame l'herbier
madame linman
madame Loisier
monsieur longuet
madame Lopez
monsieur loup
madame Lubin
monsieur Lurel
lettre M
monsieur manier
madame Mallet
monsieur Malhuret
monsieur mandeli
monsieur Marc
monsieur marchand
Madame De Marco
monsieur Marie
monsieur Marseille
Monsieur Martin
monsieur Masson
monsieur Moret
monsieur medevielle
monsieur Menin
madame mélo
monsieur Menonville
madame Mercier
monsieur merylou
madame meunier
monsieur Michaud
madame Micoulaud
monsieur Mison
monsieur Moga
Monsieur Mohamed Souali
madame Monnier
monsieur Montauger
monsieur de Montgolfier
madame Morin de Sailly
monsieur mouillé
lettre N
monsieur
monsieur Denis
madame Noël
monsieur Mougins
lettre O
lettre P
monsieur Paco
madame
monsieur panuzzi
monsieur Paul
monsieur pelva
monsieur PEMZEC
monsieur Perrin
madame Pétrus
madame finira horte
monsieur pied-noir
monsieur plat
monsieur poija
monsieur Cointreau
madame Poncet
madame Poumirol
madame Préville
madame prima
monsieur prince
madame procacia
madame puissat
lettre R
madame rack Madou
madame Raymond pavéro
monsieur Rambaud
monsieur Rapin
monsieur
Rambaud
monsieur Raynal
monsieur Redon sarrazi
monsieur Regnard
monsieur ravier
monsieur Richard
madame Renaud Garabedian
monsieur Roquier
monsieur Retailleau
monsieur Richard
madame Richard
monsieur Ritman
madame Robert
monsieur Roger
monsieur rejoint
madame rossignol
Monsieur Roux
lettre S
madame
monsieur salmon
monsieur sorry
monsieur Sautarel
monsieur Savary
monsieur Savin
monsieur Savoldelli
madame Schalke
madame Schillinger
Monsieur Seguin
monsieur sido
madame sologobe
monsieur saumon
monsieur Stanzione
lettre T
monsieur Tabaro
monsieur temal
madame tais-toi nuit
monsieur théophile
madame Thomas
monsieur Tissot
lettre V
monsieur valet
monsieur valini
monsieur Valère Henneberg
madame vaillas
monsieur Vaugrenard
madame vantalon
madame vermeiller
monsieur verzelen
monsieur VIAL
monsieur Vogel
madame Mélanie Vogel
lettre W
monsieur watteblé
lettre A
monsieur Anglard
Madame A pour sopoly
Monsieur Arnaud
monsieur Artano
madame Artigalas
madame assassin
monsieur Assouline
lettre B
monsieur babary
monsieur Jérémy Baki
monsieur Jean-Baptiste
monsieur barjoton
monsieur Bazin
monsieur de Bellay
monsieur Belin
madame Benbassa
madame Berthet
monsieur Billac
monsieur Étienne blanc
monsieur Jean-Baptiste blanc
madame blatrix compta
madame Bonfanti Dossa
Monsieur Bonhomme
monsieur bonne
monsieur Bono
monsieur bonne Carrère
madame Bonnefoy
monsieur bonus
madame boulet Sperone
madame Boura
Monsieur Jean-Marc Boyer
Madame Valérie Boyer
madame briquet
monsieur Brisson
madame Brulin
monsieur buis
monsieur Burgoa
lettre C
monsieur Cabanel
monsieur cadet
monsieur Calvet
monsieur Cambon
monsieur Canevet
monsieur capo Canellas
monsieur Capu
monsieur Cardon
monsieur Cardou
madame Carrère
madame cazebonne
monsieur chaise
monsieur chanterelle
monsieur Charron
monsieur Châtillon
monsieur Chauvet
madame Chauvin
monsieur Chevrollier
monsieur cigolotti
madame Cohen
madame Concorde
madame Conway
monsieur Courtial
monsieur Cozic
madame cucurman
lettre D
monsieur Dagbert
monsieur Dantec
madame darkos
monsieur d'Arnaud
madame Delattre
monsieur Delcros
madame Delmond Koro poulis
monsieur Dennemont
madame de scène
monsieur detrigne
madame Deveza
madame dada
monsieur Dominati
monsieur dessus
madame Drexler
monsieur Dufour
madame Dumas
madame Dumont
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur Durin
madame Duranton
lettre E
monsieur Hublet
madame Espagne
Eustache Briot
lettre F
monsieur Favreau
madame Ferrat
monsieur Ferro
monsieur Fernique
monsieur fialaire
monsieur Fichet
madame filleul
monsieur Frassa
lettre G
madame Garnier
madame Gatel
monsieur gâteau lin
monsieur gay
monsieur Genet
monsieur gold
monsieur Gontard
madame Gosselin
madame Goulet
madame gouache avant
monsieur grémillier
madame Grigny
monsieur Guinée
monsieur Guéret
monsieur guerriot
madame guidez
madame Guillotin
monsieur Guillaume
mais il va donc pas être procédé à
nouvel appel nominal puisque
donc plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite Madame et Monsieur les
secrétaires procédé au dépouillement
les résultats du scrutin numéro 94 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote nombre de votants
347 nombre de suffrages exprimés 305
pour l'adoption 197 contre 108 le Sénat
a donc adopté le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 tel qu'il résulte de
ses travaux
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous venons d'adopter ce projet de loi
de finance au terme je donne un peu de
statistique mais ça montrera votre
présence aux banques
160 heures de séances soit 10 heures de
plus il y a 2 ans tu es quand même une
durée record ce sera pour nos
méditations futures mes chers collègues
en conférence des présidents soit une
durée record depuis 1995 avec
pardonnez-moi la statistique un nombre
record d'amendements
3000 57
je souhaite vraiment remercier le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances Jean-François Husson qui par
son travail
en rigueur et en vigueur avec les
réseaux ces dernières semaines sur
l'ensemble des politiques publiques
examinées
c'est également félicité le président de
la commission des finances Claude Raynal
qui ont beaucoup capitaine a eu parfois
et même souvent choqué un peu nos voiles
lorsque l'hémicycles étaient tenté de
l'offer un peu
cela nous a permis malgré quelques coups
de vent de naviguer dans une sérénité
j'allais dire de bonne aloi pour tenir
le calendrier de la discussion
budgétaire tel qu'il est fixé par notre
Constitution
je me suis levé tous les autres membres
de l'équipage je pense bien sûr au 47
rapports spéciaux de la commission des
finances au 77 rapporteurs pour avis des
autres commissions ainsi qu'à leur
président au chef de fil des huit
groupes politiques au vice-présidents
qui ont conduit nos débats tout au long
de ces semaines je voulais les remercier
particulièrement les vices présidentes
et vice-présidents
je voudrais remercier également
l'ensemble des personnels des services
du Sénat des groupes politiques pour
leur disponibilité et leur engagement
permettez-moi de saluer particulièrement
les collaborateurs de commissions qui
ont été extrêmement présents et
les personnels du Sénat qui ont fait
face je voudrais monsieur le ministre
vous remercier je donnais le nombre
d'heures pour votre présence assidue au
cours de l'examen de ce projet de loi de
finances pour les conciliabules
nécessaires à l'extérieur de l'hémicycle
aussi qui font partie
intégrante de la vie parlementaire
je voudrais abandonner la parole au
ministre sur le président de la
commission sur le rapporteur général si
vous souhaitiez dire quelques mots
monsieur le président
je voudrais pas voir la malice
je voudrais voilà mais tout de même
c'est quelque chose assez particulier si
on fait un petit concours là de regarder
combien combien on a de chance de que ça
soit trois fois d'affilée on verra qu'il
faut c'est pas mal en statistique bien
je souhaiterais moi-même monsieur le
Président vous remercier
d'ouvrir de conclure notamment
nos débats ainsi que les vice-présidents
de séance comme vous l'avez fait qui ont
présidé à la bonne organisation de nos
travaux et je dois dire que cette année
ce ne fut pas si simple ça veut pas dire
que les années précédentes c'était très
simple mais là c'était quand même très
très particulier
saluer évidemment notre rapporteur
général qui est évidemment aux
avant-postes durant toute la période
ainsi que tous les rabatteurs peu
spéciaux rapporteur pour avis l'ensemble
des services Sénat et notamment je le
dis particulièrement ceux de la séance
parce qu'il a fallu
comment dire essayer de modifier
travailler pour que les débats se
passent au mieux et nous aurons sans
doute à progresser toujours
collectivement sur ce pote et puis comme
vous saluez notre ministre aux banques
Gabriel Attal et l'ensemble de son
cabinet et de sa disponibilité de son
envie également de parler c'est à dire
de s'exprimer d'expliquer ces positions
et c'est utile évidemment dans notre
dans notre débat vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président 3000 amendements
alors je voudrais rappeler je crois que
notre ami Jérôme Bacher l'a fait tout à
l'heure mais quand même il y a 10 ans on
était à 500 amendements 500 il y a 5 ans
on était à 1000 on est aujourd'hui à
oserais-je dire n'en jetez plus la coupe
est pleine c'est-à-dire qu'après
évidemment notre difficulté c'est de
rentrer tout ça dans un temps qui est
fixé par la Constitution et qui est fixé
comme vous le savez à une vingtaine de
journées donc ceci s'impose à nous et
nous obligera sans doute dans les mois
qui viennent à réfléchir sur
effectivement l'organisation de ce
travaux pour qu'il se passe au mieux
dans le délai contraint par la
Constitution enfin évidemment et c'était
inutile de faire tout ce travail c'est à
dire trois mois de travail en commission
trois semaines en session si évidemment
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
avait comme idée de ne pas reprendre
pleinement
en compte cette lecture complète au
Sénat mais je sais que ils vont pas
hésiter à le faire et en tire les
conséquences en vue de l'adoption du TER
du texte définitif donc merci encore un
peu de travail mais on va y arriver
monsieur le rapporteur général
chez le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues juste quelques mots
pour moi aussi adressé des remerciements
à l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs et à l'ensemble des équipes du
Sénat sur le plateau dans les coulisses
et puis dans tout le temps qui à la fois
précède l'examen du budget mais
également le temps de l'examen du budget
où je le confesse volontiers les nuits
sont très courtes elle se répètent
souvent à être très courte mais même si
c'est pas toujours un long fleuve
tranquille je dois dire que les uns et
les autres on a trouvé les modalités à
la fois de l'écoute de l'échange parfois
bref parfois plus développé je le vous
le dis c'est la troisième année l'an
dernier c'était plus court c'est
finalement à la fois c'est une forme de
marathon mais c'est aussi une manière de
sentir le coût de la France à travers
les expressions des uns et des autres
dans ma fonction je m'efforce toujours
de garder un ton à la fois juste de
temps en temps de mettre une petite
plaisanterie parce que même si il faut
être sérieux il n'empêche que on peut de
temps à autre trouver des moments de
respiration et puis monsieur le ministre
je crois que le plus important nous
attend c'est
ce qu'il reste en sortant ici du Sénat
puisqu'il n'est échappé à personne que
nous sommes dans un quinquennat d'un
temps nouveau avec une Assemblée
nationale plus complexe en termes de
majorité et de gestion et une chambre
haute qui vous donne des messages clairs
avec des positions assez unanimes sur un
certain nombre de sujets c'est ni le
moment ni l'heure de vous rappeler ce
qu'on vous propose de porter et de
garder dans le débat démocratique parce
que nous devons me semble-t-il à cette
heure prendre garde au moins d'une chose
c'est faire en sorte que le Parlement
continue d'être écouté entendu à la fois
par la voix qu'il porte mais par les
décisions qu'il prend et qu'il confie au
gouvernement notre responsabilité
collective est importante parce que on
s'apprête à mon avis à connaître des
temps plus difficiles et nous devons
être aux côtés des Français pour les
aider à traverser sans crainte
particulière sans amplifier les
angoisses mais en se donnant la main
avec les élus locaux avec l'échelle
d'entreprise pour faire en sorte que
demain en 2023 est dans les années
suivantes il fasse encore bon vivre dans
notre si beau pays de France merci
que le rapporteur général
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué en charge
des comptes publics sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs à
mon tour je vous remercie le président
de la commission des finances le
rapporteur général du budget pour ses
nombreuses heures d'examens et la
qualité du travail que nous avons eu
ensemble remercier aussi l'ensemble des
rapporteurs spéciaux et des rapporteurs
pour avis qui ont participé organisé
contribuer à ce travail qui nous a
accompagné pendant plusieurs semaines
Jérôme Bachar disait que c'était le
premier PLF sous l'empire de la nouvelle
LOLF pour moi c'était tout simplement le
premier PLF en tant que ministre du
Budget et donc le premier examen au
Sénat et je dois dire que j'ai
énormément apprécié les échanges que
nous avons eu ils ont toujours été
emprunt une très grande courtoisie
républicaine d'un très grand respect
d'une très grande écoute mutuelle et je
dois le dire ça fait ça fait du bien ça
fait du bien on a eu de vrais débats
parfois de vrais divergences je n'irai
pas jusque là mais en tout cas en tout
cas ça fait ça fait du bien et je pense
que c'est utile je pense profondément
que c'est utile vous adoptez aujourd'hui
un texte qui est assez sensiblement
différent du projet de loi qui vous avez
été présenté il y a un solde qui
s'améliore mais comme l'a dit Emmanuel
Capu en trompe l'oeil puisque c'est
essentiellement le fait de ministère et
de pas entier de l'action publique qui
sont supprimés je pense au ministère de
la cohésion des territoires au ministère
de l'Agriculture à l'action territoriale
de l'État mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que si la navette parlementaire nous
permettra évidemment de rétablir un
certain nombre de suppressions qui ont
eu lieu je crois profondément qu'il
restera la marque du Sénat dans le texte
qui sera adopté à l'issue de la navette
parlementaire parce qu'il y a des
amendements très concrets très important
pour la vie quotidienne des Français et
pour nos territoires qui ont été adoptés
il y en a beaucoup je peux pas tous les
citer mais je pense à l'amendement qui
avait été déposé par une très grande
partie des bancs je crois même
l'intégralité des groupes notamment par
Monsieur Ritman sur la suppression du
malus auto pour les 10 et pour la
protection aussi ville je pense à la
demandement qui majorent la dotation
biodiversité portée par Bernard delcro
je pense à l'amendement sur l'habitat
insalubre en outre-mer porté par Georges
patient je pense à l'amendement sur la
continuité territoriale et sur le prix
des billets d'avion porté par Madame
Jacques je pense à l'amendement sur les
prêts et les avances pour l'Iran et leur
suppression porté par Monsieur cosyx
c'est aussi un élément très important
dans le contexte que nous connaissons je
pense à de très nombreux amendements qui
sont très concrets pour nos valeurs ou
pour la vie des Français dans tous les
territoires et je pourrais en citer
d'autres il y a ensuite des
grands sujets qui ont irrigué nos débats
je revois le président de la commission
je pense aussi à ses amendements qui ont
été portés sur le financement des
nouvelles LGV très important aussi pour
nos territoires et la cohésion des
territoires les lignes à grande vitesse
et rapporteur général pour citer tout le
monde et ses amendements sur la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale issue du très
bon rapport sénatorial de la commission
des finances sur la lutte contre la
fraude il reste je le disais de grands
sujets la suppression de la CVAE que
vous avez souhaité supprimer et là je le
dis d'emblée je l'ai dit après le vote
nous proposerons à l'Assemblée nationale
de rétablir la suppression de la CVE
mais j'ai bien retenu de nos échanges
que nous pouvions aller plus loin être
plus clair sur les modalités de
compensation pour les collectivités
territoriales et croyez bien que nous
allons poursuivre le travail en la
matière pour être plus convaincant sur
le sujet il y a ensuite un nouveau filet
de sécurité qui a été adopté ici à
l'initiative du rapporteur général et de
différents groupes je ne sais pas si le
filet qui sera adopté à la fin du
processus parlementaire sera exactement
celui du Sénat ce que je sais c'est
qu'il sera différent de celui qui avait
été adopté en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale pour concerner
davantage de communes et j'ai bien
entendu là aussi le message que vous
avez porté pour que Dav de communes
puissent être concernés et être
accompagné et donc nous tiendrons compte
évidemment de ce que vous avez porté y
compris dans ce cadre là ici au Sénat
tous les sujets que je viens d'évoquer
montrent que nous avons abordé des
enjeux très concrets pour la vie des
Français et nos collectivités rapporteur
général la dit notre pays et le monde
entier connaît des troubles des
inquiétudes des angoisses et je crois
que s'il est un élément profondément
rassurant dans ce contexte c'est la
capacité à continuer à se parler à
travailler ensemble à échanger des
arguments chacun avec nos sensibilités
chacun avec nos tempéraments mais
toujours dans l'intérêt des Français et
c'est ce que j'ai vécu ici ces dernières
semaines avec vous merci à tous merci
Monsieur de ministre
je vais suspendre la séance quelques
instants pour permettre à chacun
de respirer un peu et de s'installer
pour l'examen du prochain point de
l'ordre du jour la séance est suspendue
elle sera reprise dans 10 minutes